Hello, colleagues,
students, and friends!
I hope you are having
a wonderful start
to the fall semester.
As I was preparing for the
new academic year,
which is my 11th as president,
I reflected on all that
we've achieved together
over the past decade.
And I considered
when would be a good time
for a leadership
transition here at Yale.
Of course,
we have so much more to do,
so there really is no perfect
time for one.
But right now,
we are a strong university,
and we've built momentum
for even greater achievement
in the years ahead.
So, I decided that this will be
my last year as president.
I will step down from the role
on June 30th, 2024,
unless additional time is
needed to choose a successor.
I will return to research,
writing, and, eventually,
teaching in Yale's
Department of Psychology.
So, you will
certainly see me around campus.
Of course, it's been an honor
and a privilege
to serve our university
and community.
After all,
I've been here for 42 years.
And I'm profoundly proud of the
progress we have made
to advance Yale's mission of
education, research,
scholarship, preservation,
and practice.
We've added over 2.2 million
square feet of stunning
and functional space
for research and teaching —
including the Humanities
Quadrangle,
Yale Science Building, Kline
Tower, Peabody Museum,
two new residential colleges,
the Schwarzman Center,
and so much more.
We've transformed and are
continuing to transform
Science Hill, enhanced
multidisciplinary scholarship
across the university, and
created institutes and centers
for research in the humanities,
sciences, social science,
and engineering.
We launched the Jackson
School of Global Affairs,
and we are transitioning
the Yale School of Public Health
and the School of Engineering
and Applied Science
into independent schools.
At the same time, we’ve fostered
a greater culture of innovation
Good examples are the creation
of Yale Ventures and Tsai CITY —
and nurtured increased
international partnerships
through the
Yale Africa Initiative
and other faculty-led
collaborations worldwide.
And here at home, we've
established university-wide
efforts on inclusion,
diversity, and belonging.
This year we will finish a
project focused on understanding
Yale's historical roles in
and associations with slavery.
Meanwhile, we strengthen
partnerships
with and financial support
for our home city,
creating opportunities
for inclusive growth.
We also have expanded the
faculty across the university,
and we've improved the
excellence and breadth
of faculty research
and scholarship.
And the student body doesn't
look at all like it did
a decade ago — it is
now even more promising
and diverse across every
dimension thanks to
greater affordability for
undergraduate, graduate,
and professional
school students.
For example, we expanded
the undergraduate student body
by 15% and doubled
the number of Pell-grant
eligible and first
generation college students.
Along the way, we've raised over
$5 billion through the
For Humanity campaign
toward the $7 billion goal.
And I'm not going to stop
fundraising,
even after
returning to the faculty.
You can read more about what
we have accomplished together
over the past ten years in the
accompanying Yale News story.
Of course, our work is not done.
We have a busy year ahead.
I look forward to working with
you on research
and educational programs
and initiatives
that support faculty, students,
staff, and alumni.
And we will continue to move
ahead on the planned investments
in various schools and units,
such as the expansion of faculty
facilities projects,
whether in planning
or construction phases
throughout the university.
Our partnership
with the City of New Haven;
and well-being
and Belonging Initiatives.
In the meantime, I want to
thank you for your partnership
over the years and for
your commitment to Yale.